they're such a part of my magnetic pull
to want to be a storyteller
um and i'm so excited that you
who have made all of your stories so
personal
and bared your soul and pulled from your
life experience
and told other people's stories it well
that you're on the board of ghetto film
school a non-profit that teaches
skills to aspiring young filmmakers why
is it so
important for you to pass the baton and
give other people these opportunities
that you've created so well for yourself
because i didn't go to school and go to
film school and
um you know i didn't go to co i went to
college for a year
um but i
i didn't go to film school and i i
always wanted to be a teacher
and um early on um in my career i knew
that the gift wasn't mine
you know i knew that this whatever this
was that god gave me
it is not mine it is god's and i and for
me to keep it
i have to pass it on and there are far
more
far more talented uh directors and
writers out there
that need to get passed on so um to them
so uh
i'm excited about that
i love that and what i also love is a
teacher who has
done several things because when you see
it you believe it
and we have a little surprise we have an
alumna
from ghetto film school here with us who
would like to say a little something to
you if that's okay
please welcome jillian lyons
hi hi hi
jillian hi how's it going
what are you doing drew
jillian what are you doing what are you
doing here and where have you been
are you in the business now please tell
me you are yeah
i am right now i am currently an office
pa on grey's anatomy
yes
that is so wonderful jillian i'm so
happy for you
julie let me ask you a question are you
are you are do you
you want to write correct mm-hmm
how's that going i'm still writing i'm
learning a ton
i i get to meet with the writers i get
um
you know to meet the directors um all
the producers
i'm learning get in the writer's room
julian get in the writer's room listen
i'm acting like i'm not on tv with you
now but get in the writer's room no no
as soon as you press as soon as you get
really important that you ease that
i don't get in don't fall into
production
side get stay in and focus into that
into that room where the writers are i
can't believe this drew
you guys are naughty naughty naughty you
have no idea
thank you congratulations to you is
there anything you wanted to say to lee
jillian
really just from the bottom my heart lee
thank you for all of the support you've
given
to me and to my classmates um i you know
i've said it before i
truly don't think i would be anywhere
without
you know your support i remember we we
first met at
um the table read in 2016 for the script
i wrote
and when i found out you were going to
be there i lost my mind because at the
time
you know i was literally in the middle
of watching empire i had
grown up watching your your movies with
my parents
you would go to the theater especially
to see movies done by a black filmmaker
and to get feedback from you
uh i'll never forget it um and then to
hear you at the time i was doubting
myself a little bit and to hear you say
you know you have a talent stick with it
that absolutely meant the world
and you're just your continued support
has meant
you know everything to me so i just want
to say thank you truly
very kind thanks thank you very much and
continued success to you
thank you lee you've done so many things
for so many people
honestly it just we wanted to celebrate
that
here at the show today you have changed
lives
and uplifted and supported and
transformed so many careers from writers
directors producers and actors so thank
you for all that you're doing
and thank you to ghetto film school and
thank you
shout out to get on films yes
thank you jillian so much thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]